the State Department posted a new
advisory overnight warning Americans
traveling to Saudi Arabia to exercise
increased caution Ian Lee is in Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabia's capital that's
Riyadh Ian here's a question how are
Saudi leaders responding to this attack
good morning Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman said this morning
that the country is beefing up its
defenses in the air and on the Gulf just
hours before officials here are expected
to place blame directly on Iran CBS News
has learned from a senior US official
that Saudi Arabia's air defenses were
pointed toward Yemen the same official
also claims that the radar tracks of
those drones and missiles come from the
opposite direction toward Iran to make
sure an attack like this doesn't happen
again Saudi Arabia has joined a
us-backed force to protect vital
shipping lanes and oil facilities while
asking South Korea to help bolster air
defenses but Iran still denies
responsibility and it's important to
remember that both of these countries
view each other as regional rivals
they've been fighting proxy wars in
Syria and Yemen for years and tensions
escalated recently when Iran started
seizing foreign oil tankers if Iran is
responsible for the attack it's the
first time they've directly hit Saudi
Arabia we're expecting to get secretary
Pompeius reaction when he holds a press
conference later tonight Tony
Ian leave for us on the ground in Saudi
Arabia Ian thank you very much